[Musique]
la brosse à dents de l'inconnu c'est la
meilleure chose que vous le placez sous
l'eau vous mettez l'alcool à 90 et
ensuite me brosser les dents je porte
actuellement des chaussures trop grandes
donc je vous conseille de mettre un
petit peu de coton ça passe très très
bien je préfère être à lyon avec dix
bébés qui pleurent les boules quiès
existe dans notre dos
[Musique]
un doigt dans une forte pourquoi est ce
que le petit doigt de pied mais il a
déjà souffert et bien j'ai couru couru
pour répondre au téléphone et voyez j'ai
pris le mur et à meubles au plein milieu
j'ai boîte et comme pas possible j'étais
obligé de marcher en pleine ville avec
les pieds nus une horreur
[Musique]
pour les comas gorille vous connaissez
le rasoir
[Musique]